welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar automating
cannabis testing with limbs and
laboratory automation presented by dr.
Christine Pasco vice president sales and
marketing accelerated technology
laboratories incorporated
my name is Xavier guitars and I will be
your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
libraries labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Pascal I will
now turn the presentation over to her
Thank You Xavier today we're gonna be
talking about lens and automation and
cannabis testing I've got a copy of the
abstract I don't expect everyone to read
it but I just wanted everyone to be
familiar with it and that it's there so
I wanted to go over some learning
objectives for today's presentation and
we're gonna be looking at the role that
laboratory information management
systems play along with automation and
improving analysis turnaround time and
automating laboratories that are doing
cannabis testing and also the role that
they play in facilitating regulatory
compliance we'll also take a look at
metric integration which is an important
regulatory reporting tool and then
understanding the impact of intamin
automation not just on operations but on
data quality and also final report
generation the agenda today
we'll cover items such as why bother
automating why is it important and how
can the lens actually help the cannabis
testing laboratory we're gonna look at
the elimination of mundane tests for
example manually writing out our codes
that can be automated with a label
printer and maximizing resources
providing a complete internal chain of
custody so that the laboratory has track
of the samples within their walls if
it's moved out of the incubator out of a
refrigerator I each step of the way and
then also importing facilitating
regulatory compliance and this doesn't
only relate to ISO 17025 but also
electronic signatures with FDA CFR 21
part 11
GMP good manufacturing practices and
other regulatory compliance issues as
well and then looking at metric
integration for reporting understanding
how the lens can accelerate accuracy and
efficiency and getting reports into the
hands of the users very quickly and then
finally being able to communicate the
results 24/7 with a web portal now many
people ask is it time for new lens well
there's a lot of laboratories that rely
on Microsoft Excel it's not really a
lens and there's some major flaws with
using Excel the FDA has really come down
hard in the past few years on
Laboratories that rely on Excel there's
a tool to manage data because first of
all it wasn't designed for that secondly
one of the major problems with the Excel
is that it's very easy to alter either
on purpose or accidentally results and
there's no what we call an audit trail
so that you can't tell who altered the
result why they altered the result when
they altered the result what the
original result was and what they
changed it to being able to have a Lim's
really helps the laboratory to be
bulletproof during audits so many signs
that may be time for a new lens include
failing an audit having a cumbersome
system in place that's a combination of
an electronic spreadsheet
or maybe it's a homebrew system and a
combination of lab books business needs
are rapidly changing customer demands
are increasing there's no good way to
view the entire data that you have in
your laboratory without spending hours
pulling it together in Excel and
creating macros so that you can do some
trending on that data
it's very typically without a wins it's
very difficult to train team members
because there's no good integrated
solution it's basically training on a
number of different islands of
information and often times homebrew
systems are very highly customized and
as the technology advances it's very
difficult to keep up with that you know
I spoke with the client this morning
that's called me they were still running
Windows and tea and I was shocked
because I could barely remember NT yeah
there's reasons for migrating to the
latest technology security being one on
the forefront looking at a lens it's
really a mission-critical tool for the
laboratory the lens can do so much for
the laboratory in terms of keeping track
of where samples are in the laboratory
understanding who's working on them
managing the inventory one of the worst
things that can happen to an analytical
testing laboratory is that a sample can
be lost so with the lens the samples can
be bar coded they can be managed within
the laboratory and you can also have
good control over knowing where that
sample is next being able to enter data
on those samples so once the samples log
then you can enter results for the data
so in a lot of the cannabis laboratories
the majority of the data comes directly
from the instruments and goes into the
lens this allows for accuracy and that
there's no manual data entry which can
lead to transcription errors it
accelerates the time to get a result of
the client and you can also automate
reporting such that the minute the last
results for the last test on that group
of samples is validated and approved the
report
automatically be emailed or posted to a
web portal next is quality assurance and
quality control this is also very
important not only do you want to
generate data but you want to generate
good quality data and making sure that
data is within polity control limits of
the standards that you've used on that
run being able to manage the workload in
the laboratory is also very important so
having a worthless report that allows
the analyst to know what samples they
need to work on each day is really
important it saves a lot of time and it
really promotes efficiency another area
that we're going to talk about is
instrument integration today's
laboratories have very sophisticated
instrumentation and in the past people
had done you know write down the results
from the instrument or they would have
to cut and paste them to Excel today
those instruments can be integrated
directly into the database so that data
as well as any quality assurance results
all come in to the limbs and everything
is the timestamp so that you know when
that data came off the instrument and if
your controls were artist specification
you will know right away which samples
were affected you know which samples
need to be reanalyzed we're also going
to talk a little bit about shelf-life
studies because with cannabis testing
there's many laboratories that are
becoming testing sites for the edible
industry there's more and more on
cannabis edibles that are coming to
market and it's really important to
understand just as with other food types
how long that food is viable for so you
know after six months does the active
ingredient start to wane or is it still
as potent as the date was first created
so those are the types of studies that
need to be conducted chemical inventory
is another important feature of the
limbs and that you can keep track of the
chemicals and reagents and supplies that
are used in the laboratory so for
example
if you have specific reagents that
you're using you can keep track of the
lot number the expiration date your
quantity on hand so that you know when
it's time to reorder more and then
proficiency testing many laboratories
get samples in from outside proficiency
testing centers to test the
qualifications of the analysts the
instrumentation and the laboratory to
make sure that they're getting the
results that the samples have been
spiked with employee training instrument
calibration being able to track repairs
and maintenance on all of your
instrumentation the click of a few
buttons is also very important because
if your instruments have a calibration
you don't want to be running tests on
that instrument because you don't know
how that has affected the analysis
results the CRM functionality this deals
with customer relationship management
and this is actually a very important
feature of ISO 17025 and that
laboratories now need to keep track of
the customer satisfaction aspect of
their workload so if there are any
customer complaints against the
laboratory those need to be logged and
tracked and resolved and they're
referred to as kappa's corrective and
preventative actions and then also we'll
discuss reporting not only see of a
reports a certificate of analysis or
invoices and management work list
reports but also metric reporting and
looking at electronic data exchange and
these are just data that's
electronically exported in a specific
format from the lens to a client maybe
they want it in this specific format for
their database so that they can do
trending or to another database whether
it's an ERP and accounting package or sa
key we look at standardization and
testing there's a lot of good reasons
for standardization one is being able to
train employees if you're always doing
things the same way you have standard
methods there's consistency we're
capability customers become confident in
your
product because they know that there's a
high level of quality making sure that
it's lean in terms of manufacturing that
you've worked out the process to be as
efficient as possible and providing
better service to clients now why bother
with standardization well there's a
number of reasons not only does it
improve your organization but it also
improves your bottom-line it's more cost
effective it leads to better customer
satisfaction better accuracy and
estimates of cost of services it also
allows a better employee work
satisfaction because they're very clear
on what is expected of them you can have
cross training because there's written
SOP standard operating procedure so
people know how to do each test now also
if the summit takes knowledge sharing
and learning across the organization
it's very important to have a standard
organization not only in the laboratory
but also in manufacturing if you look at
production through analysis one of the
features that a lens provides is you
actually have the ability to trace your
final product all the way back to the
lot where it was grown so if you're
working with edibles you can actually
look in the lens and look at the lot
number where if there's THC in it the
lot that was produced to extract the THC
that ended up in the final product and
this is called trace back so there's a
lot of testing that's done at every
stage of manufacturing from your raw
products your plants through your
finished students which would be your
edibles and then various steps in
between now there's different types of
cannabis concentrates if you look at you
know crumbles sugar just tool it etc you
can basically see that you won't have to
understand what you're testing for in
each sample type in each sample type
we'll need different sample preparation
so based on
sample type ear receiving the test will
vary with the lens you have the ability
to log in your sample type and then
limit to list only the tests that could
be done on that sample type so for
example if you look at the cannabinoids
there's raw dry heated age there's
certain tests that can only be done in
certain matrices so by setting these up
in the lens no one can ever accidentally
pick a test that is not possible on that
matrix so it's another area where it
really helps the laboratory to
facilitate quality now many people ask
you know we'll wait what what do
cannabis laboratories test for why do
they even bother well if you look at
cannabis especially medicinal cannabis
you may have someone that is in a
weakened immune State you want to make
sure that the final product is free of
things such as pesticides which are
sprayed on plans to make sure that the
yield is as high as it can be killing
off insects but pesticides they're
dangerous to humans so you want to make
sure that this product that you're
giving to you know potentially a
weakened population is safe the same
with mycotoxins they're generated from
molds and fungi and they can be fatal
and very very disease-causing the humans
now bacteria there's a number of
bacteria that grow on plants ecoli can
cause serious illness and this is often
used in a fertilizer to plants also
Pseudomonas there's a lot of bacteria
that although they aren't deadly to
someone with the intact immune system
anyone that's immunocompromised they
could be very very deadly too and then
also potency looking at the product what
levels are there of THC solvents
oftentimes solvents are used in the
extraction process making sure that
there's no residual solvents left over
that can be hazardous to health any
foreign materials you know organic
nutrients or you think of like mold or
anything else that it could be in your
final
sample that shouldn't be in there my
heavy metals which are toxic to humans
and their absorbed and stay with humans
for quite some time and then also water
activity that's more of a measurement of
the shelf life of the product but these
are just a few of the things that are
tested for in the cannabis laboratory
and again having a system where all
these things can be tested when the
results can be stored in one single
secure database really makes a lot of
sense from a scientific point because
then you can look at trends in your in
your samples from different growers and
you basically have the ability to get
some very good knowledge out of your
crop if you're like dealing with
different growers which grower is the
best which has the highest THC which has
the best quality we look at some of the
key limbs features in terms of internal
chain-of-custody and now keep in mind
this isn't the chain of custody form
that comes with the sample this is the
internal chain of custody so this is
when sample arrives at the laboratory
door is logged in and the custody is
turned over to the laboratory this is
what the laboratory does with that
sample while it's under their roof so if
it's pulled out of refrigerator and some
sample is removed that needs to be
documented if it's stored back in the
refrigerator that needs to be documented
who handled it how long was it out of
the refrigerator or freezer or incubator
or wherever it was stored and the beauty
of this is a lot of laboratories use
barcode so you can check things in and
check them out very effectively and very
efficiently and it also does date and
timestamp so you don't have to manually
write down you know I took it to my
bench top at 105 and I put it back at
215 that's all done behind the scenes
for you when you use the technology the
stander in the lemp's requirements for
setting up to cannabis laboratory I
think all too often people underestimate
what's involved in setting up a
laboratory it sounds simple
but I think oftentimes people forget
about things like regulatory
requirements state reporting that has to
be done and all these things take time
it's not just procuring a building
setting up with facility and setting up
the infrastructure in terms of you know
wearing a building you have to be sure
that you hire and train qualified staff
and that's often not easy because
qualified staff you know they're often
difficult to find and they need to be
fluent and I so it's international
standards organization requirements for
laboratories to become certified
cannabis laboratories are required to
become ISO 17025 certified they need to
purchase and validate their instruments
this is also something that doesn't
happen quickly it takes time to develop
methods on the instruments document the
methods validate the methods and
document the validation of those methods
authoring SOPs the standard operating
procedures and making sure staff are
familiar and comfortable with them
training on metric in receiving metric
API licences developing state approved
certificate of analysis report
submitting that information to the state
for approval and licensing for both
medicinal and recreational and then also
scheduling the 17025 ISO audit and
passing that on it so you know I'd say
ambitiously possibly 9 to 12 months this
could all be completed based on the
scope of your operation but it takes
time we look at limbs limb systems are
really very similar to an SI P for the
laboratory and then it tracks the
inventory supplies that the laboratory
purchases it manages some shelf life
studies it manages corrective and
preventative actions it manages your
instrument integration you can keep
track of your assets in the laboratory
you can configure the limbs to match
your laboratories terminology with
custom captions you can also leverage
your workflow designer to match your
business rules
as they change over time so limbs
typically have different layers that
they work with laboratory layer which is
really everything we're leading through
laboratory business layer that deals
with things such as invoicing and asset
management depreciation and then the
administration layer where you actually
have the ability to set up privileges
permissions within the system so each
user will have their unique login and
once they log in what they're allowed to
do within the system will be clearly
defined and what they're not allowed to
do will as well electronic laboratory
notebook this is something that keeps
track of unstructured data whereas limbs
are really excellent for structured data
tests that are done over and over if you
do an errand experiment where you've got
information that is kind of like a
one-time situation you might be
investigating some chemical or some
preservative and then you may never be
testing it again the electronic
notebooks are great for that so we
actually had a solution if anyone is
interested in learning more it's very
nice when the ELN is integrated with the
limbs so you can have all your
information in a single secure location
when people hear the word limbs they
often get intimidated that oh wow this
is gonna have you know so many pieces to
it and they really shouldn't because you
can break you can break it down into
very small components in this slide you
can see automated printing with a label
printer you can log in information from
a computer you can do it from a laptop
you can even do it from a tablet you
have the ability to implement bar coding
so you can have a CCD scanner you can
have 1d bar coding one dimensional two
dimensional bar coding some laboratories
they've been implement RFID tags these
are all used for positive ID to make
sure that samples aren't lost and that
you're testing the correct sample you
can also leverage dashboards so that you
can kind of see what's going on in the
laboratory and just in a snap
you have the ability to leverage
statistical analysis software to look at
trends in your data the ability to
schedule samples if you're doing a
shelf-life study for example and you
begin at time zero and you want to run
this study for six months to a year the
Lim's can actually schedule in all the
tests that you need to do and send you
an automatic reminder when it's time to
pull a sample I have the refrigerator or
the incubator or wherever that sample
has been stored and then it'll also I
mainly log in the testing that needs to
be done on that sample and then we also
mentioned instrument integration
previously so that the instruments many
of them have scanners both in so that
the samples can automatically be scanned
and then the results uploaded through
the lens along with the QC data then you
can also allow clients outside of the
laboratory behind a firewall to look at
results in the laboratory so if testing
has been completed they can see the
final completed test if testing hasn't
been completed they actually have the
ability to look at partial data of
testing have been completed to date and
the nice thing is when I work in the
laboratory
one of the biggest pains was caused to
the lab people asking for results from 6
to 9 months ago it was always very
tedious today their secure web portals
where you actually have the ability to
log in with your username and password
that is encrypted and you can see just
your results and you can take a look at
data from last week or last year or five
years ago and that's a huge time saver
and the portal also supports PDF reports
so if the client needs to access
historical data they can log in download
a PDF report and print it out and some
labs also push their invoicing to the
web portal so clients can download their
own invoices pay them download their
reports and the beauty of this is that
it's pushing the work of invoicing to
the client so the clients actually have
to use their paper their printers their
toner their time to get the invoice
report in the
Perez lutely saved of that research
Bernal also I wanted to talk a little
bit about the use of tablets in the
laboratory either on the bench for out
in the field if somebody is managing
nursery and they want to take a look at
how well plants are growing and when it
will be come to harvest them they do any
simple type of soil testing or plant
testing in the field they can actually
enter the results into the tablet and
that can be uploaded to the lens so it's
really a all-encompassing tool help
laboratories become more efficient and
manage data here's an example of some
dashboards that we talked about and
these dashboards really provide
laboratory business intelligence where
you can take the look at things like who
your largest customer is how many tests
were logged in which tests are most cost
effective if there's a test that the
laboratory runs for example that maybe
the laboratory only runs two or three a
week they may not be cost effective to
run that test so it provides metrics for
the laboratory manager to decide that
perhaps it's time to outsource that test
maybe we shouldn't be doing this test
internally anymore
and conversely if there's one test where
you have an instrument that is being
used 100% of the time it may be time to
purchase the second instrument so having
these metrics really provides laboratory
managers with the solid data that they
need to justify business decisions and
then you can also tie your fridges
refrigerators freezers incubators some
humidity chambers through Wi-Fi you can
tie them into the limbs and you can get
email or cell phone alerts if the
incubator is our temperature or for
freezer is broken down so that you don't
lose valuable on samples and the other
nice thing is you also have the ability
to put reports on these dashboards so
you could have a backlog report
reduction
or were pending report and all the
dashboards are user configurable so that
each user can see just what's important
to them and what's important to their
workflow
all right sample tracking and inventory
control no worksheets are been sheets
are used by the analyst in the
laboratory so that they know what work
they need to complete that day they can
actually leverage scanning so they can
scan a work list and then load an
instrument and then run the instrument
and then that instrument will put those
results back into the lens and it'll
print out a final report like the one
that you see in the lower right hand
portion of the screen here's an example
of also one dimensional barcode two
dimensional barcode can contain much
more information and then rfid tag which
can contain significantly more
information than the other two the nice
thing about the RFID is you can actually
track samples in real time and they are
also useful on barcodes are also very
useful for the internal chain-of-custody
one of the things that many laboratories
really struggle with is just the massive
volumes of paper that they need to deal
with being able to automate a lot of
that and put a lot of that information
electronically really saves with that
most data that's coming from instruments
can be electronically uploaded you don't
need to have people pronounce from that
being able to rapidly log samples into
the system
and leverage barcoding for scanning them
in automating your certificate of
analysis reporting to clients so when
you set up a client you can actually
enter in their email address and that
email address can be used so that once
that report for that client is complete
a PDF can be created and the report
automatically emailed to that client
along with the invoice and again it
results in a significant reduction in
paper I had one client that was
collecting field samples and you know
for regulatory purposes they needed to
keep
all of the paper that they were
collecting and the paper had to be
stored in a special humidity controlled
environment they became very expensive
that you know this paper that they had
to source so by moving to a tablet and
being able to have all that data
electronically they realized the
significant time savings and in addition
they were able to accelerate their
communication with the laboratory and
that data collected in the field could
automatically be uploaded to the lymph
system next we have a sample of a CMA
report this is just a report that came
out of one of our systems this is a
certificate of analysis and it has all
the different attributes that were
tested for the beauty of automated
reporting is that not just the speed but
the ability to quickly and accurately
generate these reports without human
intervention so once this template is
created and the testing and the
laboratories also been completed it's
been reviewed by somebody and validated
and improved
the results automatically are populated
into this template and the template can
be either reported or printed to a paper
copy or reported via the web portal in a
locked PDF or emailed in a locked PDF we
talked about instrument integration this
is something that's huge
Notah laboratory today that has a lens
has instruments that are not integrated
this is one of the areas where you get
your biggest bang for the buck it just
makes sense
instruments typically have outputs that
are a CSV file or Excel files or text
ascii xml files web services where they
have a database all of these are
electronic it can be interface with lens
there's different ways that they can be
interface but they can all be interface
many clients don't take advantage of
this because of cost but if you run the
return of your run the analysis the
return on investment is typically six
months or less it's really makes sense
from a financial standpoint and
accuracy to interface your instruments
and then some samples have built-in
barcode scanners so that you can
actually scan the samples as they're
being analyzed and along with instrument
integration users can also integrate
with different databases such as si P
enterprise resource planning databases
as well as accounting systems and others
which really makes sense because it's
electronic data to electronic data and
there's no human intervention which
translates into resource savings here's
just a slide of a few instruments that
can be interfaced we talk to people
about this all the time and not only
does it increase the data quality but it
increases accuracy it saves money it
avoids duplication of effort often times
people have to cut and paste them Excel
or they have to rekey it manually and
that just opens the laboratory up for
transcription errors again an ROI
typically less than a year I've seen it
as quick as three months but six months
is typically is a verge QC qa/qc and
trending we have actually integrated
with JM PSAs the very popular window
statistical package it allows customers
to take a look at their data with much
more granularity and for clients and
they're interested in statistics and
very very powerful because all of your
data is in the central database and it's
easily accessible with a powerful tool
such as SAS just for statistical
analysis I mean also within the
application clients can do simple
trending integrated charting they can
set up limits so if any sample has
exceeded the limit will be an automatic
color coded flag that the analyst can
quickly see and act upon the CRM we
talked about done this being an aspect
of ISO 17025 compliance customer
satisfaction so there any complaints
against the laboratory being able to
manage them is very important in design
and resource to correct that also being
able to share the
with clients via the web portal is very
important because it really puts the
power into the hands of the customer so
24/7 they can access their data they can
download reports they can view
preliminary data online they can pull it
down what trying to feed with
deliverables they can check on sample
status they have the power to do quite a
bit without calling the laboratory so
this saves the laboratory in terms of
resources the way result point works
basically everyone has to log into a
portal with their username and password
the day was encrypted so it's very
secure users are presented with the page
where they have the ability to download
a lot of PDFs or Excel files or Word
files or image files really whatever
file that the laboratory wants to set up
and share with their clients and again
the cost savings are huge we've heard
from clients that they may be just a
significant amount of money because no
longer they have to stuff envelopes deal
with postage due with client calls it's
just really streamlines recording we
talked previously about being able to
quit in the field being able to enter
results into a tablet or a smartphone it
reduces paper significantly it also
allows the laboratory to have an
electronic chain of custody and it also
eliminates the storage cost the
laboratories have for regulatory
compliance and then looking at the
ability to communicate world time with
the laboratory those are all huge
advantages so
laboratories don't do it for financial
reasons they should definitely look at
it for higher data quality reasons so
you're not recording data in the field
on papers forms and then coming back
from the laboratory I'm transcribing
them because not only does that take up
a lot more time but it also leads into
transcription errors and the ability to
introduce errors into your data today
many many consumers hear about the cloud
is an option for for using software
we found that many laboratories
especially smaller ones that don't have
a dedicated IT staff this is a great
option because there's a lower cost of
entry they don't have to have this huge
capital outlay for the software they can
basically lease the software the
server's the security the IT support
including daily backups are all taken
care of by the cloud partner looking at
this it just makes sense especially for
security issues now we really have
strong firewalls the return on
investment is fairly quick within a year
some were longer based on the complexity
of the deployment but there's a monthly
subscription fee pricing is very
flexible and it also offers long term
data storage so this is great for
laboratories that again don't have the
internal IT expertise and they don't
want to invest in the infrastructure the
servers the firewalls the network
routers and you know everything that you
may need
whereas with some from the cloud or all
you need is a device that can get on the
internet metric we talked about this
previously this is basically a
regulatory compliant system that is used
to provide oversight it provides
regulations to make sure that samples
and product that are being analyzed by
laboratories is accounted for it's it
has both an industry and regulatory side
I'm gonna talk a little bit about this
because a lot of laboratories happily
sure what they need to do for metric and
as their laboratory is getting set up
they often think this is something that
they just you know can quickly implement
in the truth is you know there's a
number of states I think it's well over
a dozen now that require metric
reporting and before the laboratories
can even report they have things that
they need to do on their side metric has
its own terminology in terms of plants
rooms and batches facilities and I have
a few slides coming up it defined all
there so every software has its own
terminology so before you can really
utilize this effectively it's important
to understand the terminology
what features are in the software how
the software can help the laboratory I
mean it also covers everything from
cultivating to selling it to patients to
infusing to transfers because again keep
in mind this is a regulatory enforcement
tracking a software package and it
eventually it comes down to tracking
taxes and fees and money so it's very
important to understand what's required
this is I'm not going to go over this
entire slide but they just wanted to
show everyone that there are many steps
that are involved to get your metric
integration it's not something that can
be done very quickly or something that
can be done in the vacuum it requires
the laboratory to complete training as
well as the Lim's vendor to complete
training so the laboratory has to
request training they have to go through
the training and completed the Lim's
vendor has to request the training they
have to complete their training upon
successful completion they're given an
API key and then that can be used to
integrate with the software so that they
can have automated reporting so if you
look at this slide and this you know you
can look at this one you have time I
don't want to read this all during the
presentation I just wanted to give
everyone a sense of what's involved so
there's a client portion up here in a
way there's a Lim's vendor portion and
blue of what's required before this can
be set up and you need to you know both
sides need to reach out to metric and
the Lim's lender needs to reach out to
metric on behalf of the client so that
metric knows the vendors working with
the specific claim as well there's a
number of states that require metric
reporting malesko Louisiana Washington
DC Maryland Massachusetts Michigan
Montana Ohio Colorado to the hunt
business and more being added so it's
important to keep checking it's one of
the things I I think is very exciting
about the cannabis testing is that it's
very very dynamic and things are
constantly evolving so it's very
important to stay up-to-date on the
latest technology
and regulatory requirements and these
next few slides are just examples of
different terminology that's used in the
metric world cannabinoids there beans
THC so it's very important to become
familiar with these cultivator
harvesters to make sure that everyone is
kind of using the same terminology and
is understanding things the same way
plants rooms benches there's a few
helpful sites that laboratories can use
to better understand what they need to
do and what what their role is and
achieving metric on certification for
their statement integration with their
lens so that they can do automated
reporting limbs and laboratory process
automation in the next section here I'd
like to talk about some of the
high-level benefits of implementing
limbs and having a quality management
system in your laboratory and also
leveraging just general automation we
talked earlier about standardization
managing time having quality data when
you're in the laboratory you don't make
widgets you generate data so it's
extremely important with the data that
you generate is a very high quality and
really lens is all about ensuring
quality data is produced and also
meeting regulatory compliance goals so
it's not just the ISO 17025
certification its requirements placed on
laboratories by the FDA if you're
manufacturing a food product then the
food safety initiatives owns a place and
cover you as well there's other a GMP
good manufacturing processes so there's
a lot of regulations some of them
overlap but it's important to understand
them all and how they affect your
business
and looking at lens the lens is not
going to make the laboratory compliant
but it's going to greatly facilitate
that compliance because they don't have
tools in place to ensure that the
laboratory makes a few
mistakes like for example when you limit
tests for specific matrix you can't pick
a test for a matrix that isn't possible
you can set up limits for your reporting
so if you have a pH test you can set
your limits of you know 114 so you can't
have a page of 21 that would be
embarrassing so the lens can kind of
prevent you from making those types of
mistakes
if you can't prevent every mistake but
they can prevent quite a few of them and
then also having the security in place
so that latter trim personnel are
assigned privileges and permissions in
the system so if I'm in microbiology I
can some chemistry data if I'm an
analyst I can enter results and review
them but I'm not allowed to approve them
rivality and that's maybe a supervisor
level so you can really statement how
the laboratory setup and crew does what
test and again it's about working
smarter or not working harder and it's a
cliche but it's so true you think about
what you're trying to do and then attack
it from kind of a scientific standpoint
it can become much more efficient here's
just a few of the benefits of automation
automated reporting I've been in
laboratories where they actually use
word templates and it's a disaster
because we as humans are very very bad
at catching mistakes so when they have
these word templates oftentimes they may
forget to keep the clients name off one
part of it and they may send it to
another client where there may be some
residual results that were from the
previous client that weren't deleted so
being able to have a fresh template each
time that's populated from a computer
from the database it's just a lot
cleaner it's a lot more accurate again
we talked about enforcing regulatory
compliance things like every sample
logged into the lens has a unique
identifier that cannot be reused when
you have a lot of book that's manually
written in humans can accidentally reuse
a number of computers won't
being able to have the qa/qc
along with the data so we can quickly
view them being able to automate
workflows and giving the analyst work
list the thing
to work on looking at instrument
calibration coming confidence in your
results because you know your
instruments were calibrated and then
there's also controls built into the
lens so that if that instrument is out
of calibration if it's so configured it
will not allow any data from that
uncalibrated
instrument to come in through the lens
it will pop up a message warning that
tells the analyst sorry that instrument
is not a calibration please find a new
instrument to run the sample on or have
an instrument calibrated being able to
manage employees training certificates
and knowing when they expire so that's
another thing where there could be
reminders in the system to automatically
send the supervisor an email saying
these ten employees are going to have
their certificate expiring soon they
need to be known sent for training
looking at instrument interfaces for
importing results into instruments
directly again test ROI makes financial
sense better David quality having a
better handle on your inventory because
each time you run a test the system can
be set up such that it pulls from
inventory how much the reagent you use
or supply for each test that you run so
it can give you a report which reagents
are running low so that you have a heads
up to order before it becomes critical
and again this is all goes to better
operational procedures in the laboratory
to be able to become more cost effective
again having a better work environment
so it's none stressful that you're
running out of reagents or running low
on supplies where there's a backlog on
the reagent or supply that you need and
then also having the ability to manage
your campus your corrective and
preventative actions this is becoming
more and more important in many
businesses where if you have complaints
against the laboratory you need to make
sure that not only you document them but
you discuss if it's you know the
seriousness of the claim is that a type
one complaint where it's very serious
the wrong results were a result were
sent to the wrong client or is it just
the time the winner report maybe take
complained what actions were taken to
mitigate that and you can also get a
chart of how long the complaint was open
who's responsible for closing in you can
put it on a calendar and said that
reminders hey you need to work on
closing out these issues this week
there's a very important tool to better
managing in the laboratory and a lot of
these outcomes in these tools are higher
customer satisfaction using advanced
analytics and trending we talked about
integration with SAS JMP software
looking at the data on statistically
with different tools being able to have
an electronic in custody I'm mobile so
you're in the field or at the bench you
can hand that paper eliminated and then
being able to not only have a data
warehouse all the results that that
laboratory is generated with web portals
such as Brazil point but also being able
to automatically deliver those results
to your clients either be email or
pushing them to the web portal and
finding an email letting them know
results are available for them so
there's just so much good that comes out
of automation it's not just all
financial there's a lot of higher data
quality benefits as well this slide
talks about efficiency savings we looked
at these are the results for five
different laboratories using sample
master rizal point sixty percent and
resource savings with Brazil point
client portal they remember this allows
clients to pick up their own reports
their own invoices looking at
improvements and laboratory processing
capabilities because laboratory is more
efficient now reduction in sample
lifecycle process time better
communication within the laboratory
streamline workflows 99.9% system
availability this was with the cloud
client
[Music]
93% reduction in time to identify
products that are us our specification
so this is what automated alerts
color coding to let laboratory analysts
know right away that there's an issue in
summary today it's really important to
look at and then
features and limbs to make sure you get
the right tool for your laboratory that
you understand the benefits positive ID
and that you also evaluate the pros and
cons of premise-based limbs versus the
clouds the premise-based is within your
laboratory where you are responsible for
the electricity the server of the
security the firewall the network all
the software the backup software the
database software the window software
the security software the antivirus
software so there's a lot a lot that's
involved or being able to outsource that
to a cloud provider that basically just
lets you run your business and basically
utilize the software and then we talked
about eliminating tasks that aren't good
use of your analyst time I mean
laboratories you often have scientists
with advanced degrees and to have them
do things like you know handwrite labels
or retain data or write things multiple
times or type things multiple times that
just doesn't make sense it's not good
use of their time or their skill set and
oftentimes in these laboratories they
have our retention problems because
people want to be challenged they don't
want to do work that they find boring
and just you know uninteresting we also
covered electronic reporting and again
that's a time savings and an accuracy
issue because the data is coming
directly from the database to metric we
discussed the fact that there's just
many many steps to metric it's not
something you just flip the switch to
there's training involved for the
laboratory there's training involved for
the Lim's provider they both need to
pass their training before they can get
to API keys limbs one of the in my
opinion one of the biggest benefits is
the ability to accrete and increase
communication across the entire
organization when I walk worked in the
laboratory the limbs we had wasn't very
user friendly so you still had to run
around the laboratory to find out who
get the sample I'm not all the data went
into the lips there were some sections
of the laboratory that had my lips for
you had the X
look up results and it was really
frustrating it was really a waste of
time for a lot of people working in the
laboratory on a limb as in laboratory
automation they have a very very fast
return on investment and you can imagine
you know all the things were little lens
touches from sample login through final
sample disposal through the utilization
of our codes it really is about being
efficient and effective in the
laboratory then we also talked about
regulatory compliance cannabis
laboratories are required to be a nice
little 17025 certified so from this
standpoint the Lim's really helps the
laboratory become bulletproof windows
authentication is often deployed we've
talked about 21 CFR part 11 compliance
this is for electronic signatures and
then this comes from the FDA this
basically says each user needs to have
their own unique username and password
and deals with electronic signatures
within the lens for specific functions
that are executed another important part
of cannabis testing is having a very
bulletproof internal chain of custody
and audit trails so that if any results
are changed within the system the system
keeps track of who entered the original
results what the original result was 18
time stamps of the original results and
then the new results with 18 time stamp
we're result the reason for the change
and then who made the change so all of
that is tracked by the users username
and password when they log into the
system so having that audit trail is
very important some laboratories have an
audit trail report and they use it to
see how different employees are doing
sometimes when you have a new employee
and they have to find a lot of their
results it can turn out to be a training
issue and that person may just need more
time and more training so these are kind
of the key takeaways and features of
having limbs and some of the benefits of
the lens but was a paper that just came
out last month in this month it's called
selecting the limbs from canvas industry
it was in the January February
20-19 issue anyone's interested in
giving a copy
feel free to email info of a celeb calm
and we'll be happy to send you a copy of
that paper finally it's well thank
everyone for their time and there's any
questions please don't hesitate to reach
out thank you doctor Pascoe for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible now
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June of 2019
and as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye